look at this photo carefully
i want you to tell me how does it make
you feel do you feel that you can trust
this woman or sympathize with her
or does her appearance frighten you a
little bit perhaps the more closer you
look at her features the more you look
into her eyes the more uncomfortable you
find yourself feeling there's clearly
something not quite right here well
congratulations you've just proved that
you're not a robot without having to
click on pictures of bosses and typing
out random streams of letters
this face was actually generated by
neural network
i took it from the website this person
does not exist
every time you refresh the page a neural
network based on nvidia's style gang
algorithm creates a new face this is
sometimes used by scammers taking these
portraits of non-existent people and
using them to register fake accounts on
social networking sites forge documents
or pass them off as creators of crypto
projects but these computer-generated
people continue to unnerve me
there's clearly something a little off
about them today we're going to look
into the future and discuss what's on
the horizon for the human race my name
is emily and this is some sub a channel
all about how to survive in the online
jungle i'm pleased to invite you today
on an expedition to uncanny valley
[Music]
now do you remember these guys
in 1987 they became the symbol of mtv in
fact the channel began its first
european broadcast with a clip of these
pixelated little men from the dire
straits money for nothing video the
video went on to become the best music
video of the year and the hallmark of
the bosch fgs 4000 graphics station
at that time it was considered a real
breakthrough the ats were a time of
incredible optimism about the future of
computer technology
a wave of the first truly affordable
computer systems had flooded offices and
educational institutions computers were
taking over television the publishing
business the financial sector and we
believe that that technology would bring
new wonders but 30 years later and it
was rugged vikings who were making their
attempt to capture cinema screens 450
animators worked with robert zimeki's
film they processed the movements of the
actors working from recordings of a
whopping 200 cameras the production of
beowulf cost 150 million and
it completely flopped at the box office
despite all of the hard work of
designers and animators the audience
just didn't like the characters and this
wasn't the first failure of computerized
actors a few years previous there was a
similar story with final fantasy the
spirits within and demeki's previous
film with a similar style the polar
express was hardly a success so why did
we like the characters of money for
nothing even though they barely move in
the frame and yet we didn't fall in love
with the almost real heroes of zemeckis
it's all about that word almost in fact
this effect was described in detail by
an article by japanese engineer masahiro
mori back in 1970
and in 1978 jessie reichard translated
the article into english for the first
time suggesting that we name the
phenomenon described by masahiro as
uncanny valley now what do you think the
japanese engineer wrote about since
computer characters were still very far
off in the future at that time
well
maurice research was dedicated to robots
before the advent of mori's research
engineers and science fiction writers
were united in their opinion the future
belonged to humanoid robots machines
should become as similar as possible to
their creators now remember all fiction
was filled with androids
androids translated from greek means
humanoid
now take a look at the first android
from great britain it was built by
captain william richards in 1928.
eric as the world war one veteran called
his robot made a real splash at the
exhibition of the society of model
engineers
the robot on its stage gave a speech
that opened the event
but don't you think he's still quite far
from an accurate image of a man eric in
fact is more similar to our angular
heroes of the dire straits clip over the
next half a century robots began to
resemble man more and more
compact and powerful drives were at the
disposal of engineers and the
development of electronics made it
possible to control hundreds of motors
and sensors in real time prototypes of
robots began to appear that resembled a
human not only in appearance but also in
movement but mori argued that there was
a huge obstacle in the way of progress
at first as the mechanism begins to
become human-like it evokes positive
emotions in people but if you make a
robot too similar to a human then it
actually has the opposite effect
sympathy wanes and in its place comes a
feeling of anxiety dislike even
rejection maury described this pattern
for two types of objects at once
static mobile and revealed that for
moving objects in particular robots this
effect is much more pronounced and more
he really was ahead of his time
when he wrote the article he only
imagined such robots therefore he made
comparisons with zombies or medical
prosthesis
but now we can see just how right he was
this is sophia
the first robot in the world to
officially obtain citizenship and a
passport now there's no doubt about
severe's intelligence she quickly
answers the questions of tv presenters
enters into friendly skirmishes with
elon musk and speaks at the un
what cheese can never be yours
my cheese can never be mine i don't know
nacho cheese
however there are clearly huge problems
with her appearance sophia's facial
drives can give her 60 different
expressions
but
could you really mistake her smile for a
real person personally she gives me the
creeps but why is that maury himself
tried to explain the uncanny valley
effect by using a person's natural fear
of death
over the course of our evolution our
brain has excellently learned to
distinguish living objects from
inanimate objects a living person or
animal doesn't invoke significant fear
in us initially anonymous objects stone
or wood are also familiar for us but if
an initially inanimate object starts
moving
it scares us and this fear sits deep
within us remember the jewish legends
about gollums
they've been scaring humanity for
hundreds of years on the other hand if
you've ever been to madden two swords
the wax museum
it's pretty unlikely that one of the
exhibits there seriously scared you we
of course can understand that these are
just wax statues and therefore we're not
afraid of them instead we can just
wonder at the skill of the creators but
in the case of robots and cgi characters
another fact comes into play death the
corpse of any living creature is an
unambiguous danger signal to our brain
the cause of death can be a predator a
poisonous plant a natural disaster it
doesn't matter what but seeing even a
dead pigeon or a fish floating in an
aquarium and our brain sounds the alarm
now cross this fear of death and
inanimate objects coming to life and you
get a reanimated corpse frankenstein's
monster count dracula or a zombie
therefore modern androids are not yet
humanoid but more zombie-like robots now
you can be the judge yourself professor
hiroshi shiguru has been creating
natural looking robots for more than 30
years he even created his own mechanical
avatar but let's be honest would you
really be able to get the two mixed up
[Music]
so the neural network in our head is
able to distinguish artificial
characters robots or cgi from ordinary
people extremely well
but how does it do it well it's all
about mirror neurons
they're located in multiple different
parts of our brain and are responsible
for our ability to imitate to copy the
behavior of other people and to learn to
talk
and they also determine our empathy
level
thanks to them we can empathize with
other people when we communicate with
another person our brain closely
monitors the facial expressions of our
conversation partner our mirror neurons
copy any micro movements of the facial
muscles and thanks to this we can
ascertain the emotions of our partner
faulty operation of mirror neurons
according to one of the most popular
theories is actually one of the factors
at play in autistic spectrum disorders
but in the case of androids most of our
mirror neurons simply do not receive
familiar signals
the brain finds itself in an unfamiliar
situation and this is always interpreted
by our consciousness as a threat if
you've ever spoken with people who
suffered a stroke or are maybe partially
paralyzed due to some kind of health
condition or accident then you may have
experienced an initial discomfort that
made it difficult for you to look at
your conversation partner
the same discomfort arises from
insufficiently animate faces of robots
or virtual actors why the very best
hiroshi ishiguro animatronics have 50
degrees of motion but that's still too
little for example just to smile the
body uses 57 facial muscles
and their combinations are much more
complicated than ishiguro servos now
this variability causes no fewer
problems for 3d animators
initially they tried to take the
approach of creating realistic models of
the character's faces with huge amount
of detail muscles and bones but
eventually switched to the technology of
capturing the faces of real actors
and it was exactly this that played a
cruel joke on the creators of beowulf
image capture works with a limited
number of points and actors are required
to act quite differently than they're
used to in front of conventional cameras
this is exactly why this man has become
one of the most sought after actors in
hollywood maybe don't recognise him well
actually you're looking at gollum from
the lord of the rings
caesar from the planet of the apes
captain haddock from tintin and also
king kong and baloo his name is andy
circus and thanks to his mastery of his
facial muscles the british act has
become a hollywood superstar the main
secret to his character's success is
that they evoke the correct response
from our mirror neurons
hence we're able to empathize with these
computer models as if they were living
beings but if we've learned to
emotionally deceive people using motion
capture maybe we should try to deceive
the neural network of our brain with an
artificial neural network well
people have already begun to make such
attempts do you remember my video about
reviving pinup girls using the company
did's neural network
i deliberately used not only old photos
but drawings of people and why
well it was to provoke the neural
network to demonstrate the uncanny
valley effect when artists painted these
girls they idealized their faces made
them more symmetrical aligned their
features remove small flaws this of
course gave them a special beauty and
charm and to our brain seems absolutely
natural but this was because our brain
could still identify that they were
drawings and so could enjoy looking at
them
but the moment i brought them back to
life i created digital zombies
they don't make us feel good
they actually scare us a little bit in
addition we don't expect absolute
perfection of a human face in fact we're
even a little bit afraid of absolute
symmetry
look at these photos by alex beck
now these are real people it's just that
the photographer only used one half of
their face
mirroring it in photoshop asymmetry and
minor flaws are what makes us
recognizable as a living being
symmetrical faces look unnatural and
this is often forgotten by the creators
of robots or video game characters
[Music]
but there's one final important point in
its six million years of existence
humanity has only been dealing with
artificial beings for a few decades
our brain has simply never encountered
such objects before but it's able to
adapt incredibly quickly
recently i came across a study that may
negate the uncanny valley effect
dr kimberly brink conducted a study of
the emotional perception of robots by
children aged 3 to 18 years
and the reaction of children who were
aged 9 years or younger surprised
scientists they weren't confused by the
similarity of robots humans although
older teenagers showed a clear dislike
for these beings
researchers have suggested that at a
young age people are more trusting they
don't automatically perceive a threat
from these strange creatures and with
age this perception of the world changes
we learn to perceive and interpret other
people's emotions better and therefore
become afraid of these unfamiliar robots
but there is another explanation our
children are already used to living side
by side with artificial beings
3d characters have become an integral
part of their world and the brain is not
used to expecting them to fully comply
with human behavior perhaps our children
will stop separating artificial and real
people in the same way that we have
learned not to divide others by skin
colour maybe we'll learn to perceive
artificial people as they are without
waiting for the addition of hundreds of
new surveys to their faces well if you
have small children why don't you
conduct a little experiment show them
the footage from this video and ask them
what they think about the characters
we've shown here
and of course if you do this please
share your results in the comments we'd
love to hear about it in addition
technology sometimes develops at an
unprecedented pace look at these photos
in which row do you have the most trust
the most confidence
the top row or the bottom
if you chose the top row then the neural
network has successfully managed to
deceive you
but you're not alone
223 people from a study which was
published a few months ago also chose
the top row in february 2022 sophie j
nightingale and harry fareed ask
volunteers to rate how much they trust
these individuals on a scale of one to
seven
consequently the results of the neural
network evoked the greatest trust and
the photos of real people evoked the
least
so now do you understand why network
scammers are so fond of this person does
not exist it remains for me to add that
digital artists have also learned to
consciously use the uncanny valley
effect to their own ends
think of the white walkers from game of
thrones the dementors from harry potter
or the nurses from silent hill
now admit it they're really creepy it's
good that they exist only on the screen
at least for now okay so that is all for
today my name is emily this is some sub
and thank you for joining me on this
expedition through uncanny valley
now we would love to hear from you what
do you think about cgi characters are
they realistic do you empathize with
them leave your comments down below we
would love to hear them
[Music]
[Music]